I'll begin reading in verse one and we'll read to the end of the Psalm.
Oh, Lord, my God, in you do I take refuge.
Save me from all my pursuers and deliver me.
Lest like a lion, they tear my soul apart, rending it in pieces with none to deliver.
Oh, Lord, my God, if I have done this, if there is wrong in my hands,
if I have repaid my friend with evil or plundered my enemy without cause,
let the enemy pursue my soul and overtake it and let him trample my life to the ground
and lay my glory in the dust.
Arise, oh Lord, in your anger.
Lift yourself up against the fury of my enemies.
Awake from me.
You have appointed a judgment.
Let the assembly of the peoples be gathered about you.
Over it, return on high.
The Lord judges the peoples.
Judge me, oh Lord, according to my righteousness and according to the integrity that is in me.
Oh, let the evil of the wicked come to an end and may you establish the righteous.
You who test the minds and hearts.
Oh, righteous God.
My shield is with God, who saves the upright in heart.
God is a righteous judge and a God who feels indignation every day.
If a man does not repent, God will wet his sword.
He has bent and readied his bow.
He has prepared for him his deadly weapons, making his arrow arrows, fiery shafts.
Behold, the wicked man conceives evil and is pregnant with mischief
and gives birth to lies.
He makes a pit, digging it out and falls into the hole that he has made.
His mischief returns on his own head and on his own skull.
His violence descends.
I will give thanks to the Lord.
The thanks due to his righteousness.
And I will sing praise to the name of the Lord the most time.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
Lord, I pray that as we approach your word now that we would do so with with
Thanksgiving, Lord, you are the righteous God and you have given us your
perfect word.
It's Lord, I pray that you would give us ears to hear and hearts ready to
respond in faith to what you'd have to say to us in Jesus' name.
Amen.
The last long call flight I took, I found a show that I watched that I
just could not look away from.
And so I was there, just binged it across the entire Atlantic Ocean.
And so it was called, what was it called?
Yes, Mr. Bates and or Mr. Bates versus the post office, rather.
I don't know if you've ever come across it before.
It's a BBC docu drama.
But it's the story of Alan Bates.
And he was a post postal worker in Wales.
And he and many other postal workers, about 700 total, were falsely
accused of fraud.
This is a totally true story.
And of course, being accused of fraud, they lost their reputations.
But also they lost a lot of money to they were having to pay back, you
know, the kind of the shortfalls that were there.
Many of them lost their jobs and hundreds of them, over 200 were
actually thrown into prison because of this false accusation.
And while they were still maintaining their innocence, there was a
man who had experienced this very thing called Alan Bates, who then discovered
like he wasn't the only one who had experienced and started to bring other
people around him who'd experienced the same thing.
And that eventually led to a campaign where they then brought the
National Post Office to court in 2017.
And they ended up, many of them being exonerated and exposed what was
thought by many to be the most widespread miscarriage of justice in
UK history.
And so it's really moving, particularly to see that the toll, the mental
and physical toll that it took on people who were being falsely accused
and to then see them campaigning to bring this to court and then finally
to be recognized as being innocent.
So it was a really moving thing to see that movement.
But then by the end of it, there was still a lingering sense of how
could this have happened in the first place and has justice really
been served?
And so it kind of created this longing for justice as you were watching it.
Well, this morning we're looking at Psalm seven and in Psalm seven,
there is a longing for justice.
It's written by David as he is experiencing a time of personal injustice.
And he's he's crying out to God for deliverance, bringing his case to him.
And but he is confident that justice will be served as he brings this to
the Lord.
But why is he so confident that when he brings injustice before the Lord,
that justice is going to be served?
What gives him that kind of confidence?
Well, we see in verse 11, it's a phrase that he starts with in that verse.
And it is this, God is a righteous judge.
God is a righteous judge.
So in a world of injustice, this Psalm invites us to pray and live
in the hope of knowing that God is a righteous judge.
And that's the kind of the title for today, if you will, just just those words
from the start of verse 11, God is a righteous judge.
Now, I realize that saying anything about God as our judge
doesn't sound like good news to modern ears.
Like folks are OK with us hearing about God being loving things like that.
But to say that God is a just judge, people recoil at that.
But in Scripture, we see clearly that, yes, God is a loving savior,
but he is also a righteous judge and both are incredibly important.
And even in his justice, we see his his love displayed, so you cannot get one
without the other.
So for the next few moments, I want us to just look at three reasons
from Psalm seven about why it is important to know that the Lord is a righteous judge.
We're going to see, first of all, that he cares about injustice.
And then we're going to see that he delivers the innocence.
Then we're lastly going to see that he achieves ultimate justice.
So that's why it's important.
So it's important that we see that God's a righteous judge
because we can know that God cares about injustice.
So when God looks on at a world full of injustice, he is not distant and aloof.
He cares about the injustice in the world.
So David brings his situation before God because he knows that God cares about injustice.
So let's look together about at what David is experiencing.
Poor David once again is surrounded by enemies.
If you feel like you've heard that before, it's because we've seen that in the last several Psalms.
And I can't wait till Psalm eight next week to finally get some praise
and some some some joy in there, too.
But here, David is once again being attacked and uses vivid imagery
to describe the attack that he is under.
He's praying that the Lord at verse one would save him and deliver him
because his enemies are like a lion.
So he says, less like a lion, they tear my soul apart,
rending it in pieces with none to deliver.
So this attack he is under is is fierce and it is deadly.
Interestingly, the apostle Peter uses this same kind of imagery
to describe Satan and his attacks on the people of God.
So first Peter, chapter five and verse eight says this,
it says, be so reminded, be watchful.
Your adversary, the devil, prows about like a roaring lion,
seeking whom he may devour.
So here, David is being attacked in this way by a roaring lion,
seeking to devour and his enemies are using one of Satan's favorite weapons.
And that is a lie.
That's what they're bringing.
So David's under attack because he is being falsely accused.
We don't know what he's being accused of, but we do know,
according to what David's saying here, that the accusation is absolutely false.
He is so convinced of his innocence that he prays something really bold.
Let's read it again.
Verse three, he says, Oh, Lord, my God, if I have done this,
this thing I'm being accused of, if there is wrong in my hands,
if I have repaid my friend with evil or plundered my enemy without cause,
let the enemy pursue my soul and overtake it and let him trample my life
to the ground and lay my glory in the dust.
So what's he saying here?
He's saying, if they're telling the truth, then let my enemy succeed.
If I'm really guilty of what they're accusing me of, then let them take me out.
So that is how confident he is that he is being treated unfairly.
I wonder if you can identify with what David is experiencing here.
Maybe you know what it is to be judged unfairly or to be falsely accused.
I couldn't help but think of something that happened when I was in college.
I was brought brought aside by a resident assistant
and he came over, he said, Brandon, I need to speak to you over here.
So he pulled me into a room and he said, he says,
I know that you have a real problem with speeding.
He says, I've heard about how fast you drive.
And he said, he said, and sure enough, he said, I was on the road
and your blue Nissan Pathfinder went flying by me down the road.
And and I was just I thought, well, I don't always drive under the speed limit.
But this doesn't sound like me.
This doesn't sound like I'm fast and furious,
breaking the road all the time.
And I and I decided to maintain my innocence.
I said, that could not have been me.
That that wasn't me.
Like, I'm not driving as fast as you're describing all the time.
And he he was he was coming right back at me, saying, like, I saw you.
Stop trying to hide your sin, you know, and that kind of thing.
He was he was really going for it.
And I said, I'm innocent.
I didn't do this.
And a few days later, lo and behold, I was driving down a road
near that very spot where we had the conversation
in a blue Nissan Pathfinder, the same year as mine, went flying
past me down the road and it had a sticker on the back
saying that they were a student at the same college that I was a student at.
And so I kind of broke my rule of not going past the speed limit, you know,
and I flew down the road to catch this person, whoever they were.
So I was flying on the road and sure enough, I found like, OK,
who is the student?
What dorm do they live in?
And it didn't take but I don't know, maybe an hour before I found
the person who was accusing me.
And I said, just so you know, this other student drives a blue
Nissan Pathfinder and here's how fast he was going.
I'm innocent. I'm innocent.
So I was I was claiming this before him.
That, of course, is just a small example that I'm sure you can think of
examples in your own life where you've been falsely accused.
But this can happen in very serious ways, like ways that are
devastating for people, life changing when you have false accusations.
I particularly think of, you know, people being accused of, say,
a crime that they did not commit and the loss
of reputation that comes with that.
On the flip side, you can have a victim who has genuinely been the
victim of a crime and they are then falsely accused of, say,
lying about it or or attention seeking or money grabbing or something like that.
So that's why people don't come forward, even though they've actually
been a victim, lest they be falsely accused.
So false accusation can be devastating to experience that kind of injustice.
You know, when Jesus came into this world, he experienced injustice to the full.
He experienced false accusation.
So he spent a lot of time, if you read the Gospels, you see,
he spends a lot of time eating and drinking with people.
And so people that said, aha, he's a he's a drunkard and he's a he's a
glutton because he eats with people, false accusation.
He cast out demons.
All right. So he's got spiritual power.
And so people say, aha, no, he's he is demon possessed.
That's why he can do all of that.
So another false accusation.
When it comes to his trial, we're told that they're they brought forward
many false witnesses, they're laying false accusations at him.
And we're even told they couldn't get their stories together.
But all of that was taken and included in finally convicting him
and sentencing him to death on the cross.
So he was a victim of of injustice that came through false accusations.
You know, while I am I am grateful for the common grace of our justice system.
And this is a way of God bringing justice in the world through through
institutions of of justice that he has established.
We also live in a world we have to say where injustice still exists,
where false accusations are made, where people are falsely accused
or even imprisoned or or we experienced just at a personal level.
Injustice being treated unfairly, you know, could be something at work
where somebody gets a promotion, where when you were the one who actually deserved it
or gets credit for something that you did, we all experience all kinds of injustice.
It's troubling when our when our names or our reputations
are being aligned and drug through the mud and we cry out.
This is not fair like David, we cry out maybe to the Lord saying, this isn't right.
But let's let's lean into that.
So this is what David does when he experiences this injustice.
He cries out to the Lord.
That's how he responds.
And the fact that he is doing that means that he knows if I can do this
because God cares about injustice, it's his character.
So when he says God is a righteous judge, he's saying, God,
I'm I'm reminded of what of your characters.
I know that you will hear this cry of unfairness that I'm bringing before you.
And when it speaks about God's righteousness and his justice,
these two are often wedded together in scripture.
So you go back right back to Genesis, Genesis 18, 25.
It says, shall not the judge of all the earth do right?
So he's a judge and he judges righteously.
Deuteronomy 32, 4, just and right is he.
Second Timothy chapter four and verse eight in the New Testament.
He is a righteous judge.
OK, so God is the to say that this is about God's character here.
This is to say that God is the standard of righteousness.
And so when he judges, he judges according to his own perfect righteousness.
So if he is perfectly righteous, that means that all of his judgments are right.
There is no injustice with God and his character or his actions.
You know, when it comes to our legal systems in the West,
we separated out into different roles and responsibilities.
When we talk about God as the righteous judge,
all of these are bound up in him, ultimately, as in the different roles
and responsibilities that we might pull out in different directions.
So, for example, God is to say that he's the righteous judge.
Just to say that he's the legislator, right?
He gives the law.
He is the one who says what is right and what is wrong.
And he reveals that in his word and he writes that on our hearts.
Right? So he's the one who legislates, but he's also the jury.
Right? He weighs the evidence of right and wrong that has been committed.
He reaches a verdict. Nothing is hidden from his sight.
But he's also the judge, you know, in the sense that he passes the final sentence.
Then we even get to the point of, yes, he is judge, jury and executioner.
So he is the one who enforces the sentence that is carried out.
He ensures that justice is served.
All that's connected to his character as the righteous judge.
But don't think of that in like a, in a way once again, where he's a loof.
It's not like he's just just throwing a book at injustice.
It's not that he's unfeeling.
God cares deeply about injustice.
So verse 11, God is a righteous judge and a God who feels indignation every day.
All right. So speaking of God's anger about injustice here.
This is what relates to his love as well, because God, God loves his people.
He is angry at the injustice that we face in the world.
So when you look at some of the horrific things that are being perpetrated
in the world or even just locally, and it makes you want to take action
to do something, to cry out, we might wonder, well, where's God?
And does he care? Is he unfeeling about this?
The answer is no.
He feels indignation towards the injustice that is committed.
In fact, Romans chapter two in verse five says that he is storing up wrath
for the day when his righteous judgment will be revealed.
So when we experience unfairness and injustice, we can cry out to God
knowing that he cares.
You know, our instinct may be to immediately take things into our own hands
and defend our reputation or our good name or to try to get revenge personally.
But we would do well to follow the example, not only of David, but of Jesus.
First Peter once again, First Peter chapter two in verse 23,
where we were just told to follow in Jesus' steps,
were to follow in his steps because when he was reviled, it says,
he did not revile in return.
When he suffered, he did not threaten but continued
entrusting himself to the one who judges justly.
He was accused and entrusted himself to God, who is the righteous judge.
And we could do the same because God cares.
But secondly, we can also do that knowing that God delivers the innocent.
So God delivers the innocence.
So David is taking refuge in God and asking him to save him.
But you might say, well, David, how do you know that God is going to save you?
How do you know that he is going to deliver you?
Well, he says it again in verse 10.
He says, my shield is with God.
Who saves the upright in heart?
So David is confident that God will deliver him because God saves the upright.
David's confident that he's going to be saved because God delivers the innocence.
Now let's go back to verse eight.
David says something here that made my Protestant knees knock this week.
Let's let's read it together.
It says, the Lord judges the people.
So we've just seen that.
He says, bold prayer here.
Judge me, O Lord, according to my righteousness, according to the integrity that is in me.
What a prayer.
You might read this and think, that's that's bold, David.
And the more and the more you think about it, the more think, well, David's lost it.
This is actually an insane prayer.
You know, after all, you know, there is no one who is righteous.
No, not one.
Right. You're reading like Romans three or you hear the prophet Isaiah saying
all our righteousness is as filthy rags.
And you think, well, David, have you forgotten about the whole thing
with like Bathsheba and, you know, getting her husband murdered?
And so David clearly a sin.
So how can he pray, Lord, judge me according to my righteousness?
Well, first of all, let's say what he's not saying.
OK, he is not saying that his righteousness, his own inherent righteousness
is his source of justification before God.
Right. He's he's not saying that here.
You can look at other Psalms.
So take Psalm 51, for example, where David clearly acknowledges his sinfulness
before God.
Psalm six, we began last week with that.
Hims clearly throwing himself on God's mercy, knowing that he needs God's mercy.
Why? Because he's a sinner.
Right. So David's not saying he is perfectly righteous here.
So let's not kind of import that into that.
That's what made me nervous.
Like looking at that.
Well, what's he saying here?
All right. Here's here's what he's saying.
The righteousness he is speaking about when he prays that God would judge him
according to his righteousness is not perfection, but innocence regarding
whatever it is that he's being accused of here.
Right. It's not perfection, but innocence in this particular matter.
He's saying, Lord, when I'm speaking here, unlike my accusers,
I am speaking with integrity.
That's what he says, judge me according to the integrity that is in me.
In other words, what I am saying lines up with the facts.
I'm not hiding anything.
I'm speaking with a clear conscience.
And Lord, you know all things.
You are the one who tests the minds and the hearts.
You know that I'm innocent in this matter.
Right. So you think about people who are who have been committed of crimes.
I was also reading about over the past 30 years or so that, you know,
with with DNA testing being developed and brought being brought into like court cases
that there's now people who are convicted years ago who are now being found innocent
because of that. And there have been hundreds of cases because because the
evidence is then like irrefutable in some of these cases.
This could not have been this person.
But David knows that he lays out his case before the Lord.
But he knows that. So what does he say?
Yeah, verse nine, the Lord tests the minds and the heart.
Lord, you see what's going on here.
You know that I'm righteous in this matter.
You know, I'm innocent. So save me.
Deliver me from this.
So what does this mean for us?
What means that? Well, everyone who belongs to the Lord can commit
whatever unfair situation they are in knowing that God knows the truth.
Other people might be falsely accusing.
Your your reputation may be unfairly tarnished, but the Lord sees you.
The Lord knows the truth.
Write down to your very, you know, motives.
He sees us through and through.
And we can commit these these situations we go through knowing that God knows the
truth and he's a God who delivers.
He's a God who saves.
God can even he can bring us out of that unjust situation and show that we
were right or or he could also work through that unjust situation to bring
about a greater good in our in our lives.
You know, so think about the injustice faced by Joseph.
I mean, talk about somebody who was falsely accused and imprisoned.
He was he went through some horrible things.
But in the end in Genesis 50, what does what does what does Joseph say?
He says, you meant it for evil, but God meant it for good.
Right. So God worked through this evil situation for the greater good,
for the salvation of others even.
And then look at the ultimate example of Jesus,
who is maligned and mistreated and even crucified, executed for no wrongdoing
of his own and yet God through this great injustice brought about a greater good.
Right. So God can deliver us and bring about good.
But the greater good that was brought about through Jesus and his death.
Well, the fact that sinful people like us can be made righteous,
righteous in that sense of being justified, being declared righteous by God,
not just innocent in a particular situation, but seen in the very righteousness of Jesus.
And the reason that can happen is because the judge came into this world
and took upon himself the judgment that we deserved.
We might instead receive God's mercy, because God's judgment,
the judgment that you and I deserve because of sin was satisfied at the cross.
So Jesus took our sin.
What do we get in return?
Righteousness. So we can pray.
Lord, deliver me according to the righteousness that you have given me in Jesus.
So God saves the righteous.
He saves those who are in Christ clothed in his righteousness.
Yes, scripture speaks about Satan being a roaring lion seeking to devour us.
But he also speaks about our scripture, speaks about him being an accuser
of the brethren.
And that's another thing that a way of speaking about what Jesus accomplished
at the cross is he came to defeat our accuser, to bring him down, to
bring his works to an end.
So he's defeated the accuser of the brethren through his finished work.
And we have this advocate before the Father in heaven.
We stand in his righteousness.
So God saves the righteous.
But then finally, God insures or achieves
ultimate justice.
So we cry out to God, do you care?
Yes, he cares.
Deliver me. Yes, he delivers us in Christ.
And we can pray that the knowing that he will bring about ultimate justice.
I love the quote that was popularized by Martin Luther King, Jr.
He said, the arc of the moral universe is long, but it bends towards justice.
You see that same sentiment here in what David is saying.
David is putting his hope in God as the righteous judge, knowing that
however long it takes, justice is coming.
In the end, justice will arrive.
So David talks about it in a way about the coming justice of God
in a way that's almost like darkly comedic, like if you like a good
dark comedy or the other story or a movie.
But yeah, so when you read about how David talks about it, you know,
he talks about God getting his weaponry ready.
He says, if man does not repent, God will wet his sword.
He's he's bent and ready to his bow.
He's got his he's got his arrows lit and ready to go.
You know, he talks about somebody conceiving evil and being pregnant
with mischief, giving birth to lies.
And then and then talks about them digging a pit.
And then they they fall into the pit that they have made.
So so just go back to that.
So God has his weaponry ready.
And I'm seeing some of you and I know you like weapons and you want to get
some men's men's or kind of group me going, you just start talking about,
you know, who's got this particular gun or this particular part.
And I'm not looking at anybody in particular.
But I know there's folks in here who like that kind of thing.
All right, well, this is this Psalm is for you. Right.
So God is laying out all of his arsenal.
And he's saying it's it's it's ready to go.
These lions have surrounded David.
Yes, but there's this kind of hunting image here and God is ready to defend David.
They're not going to get away with this.
Justice is coming.
This this pit that they're digging for David, they are going to fall into it
themselves. Their sinful attack is like it's like a boomerang
that's going to come right back and take them out.
I'm not sure if you're familiar with the story of Esther in scripture.
But that's the same thing happens in the book of Esther.
You've got you've got the king and or this guy who works for the king called
Haman, you read about this in Esther seven and Haman wants to see the destruction
of the Jews and it's going to begin with.
He he wants to see Mordecai hanged and then the Jews then defeated and destroyed.
And so he prepares these these gallows that are ready for Mordecai.
But in the end, even though he's prepared these gallows and they're ready to go,
the tables then turn and Haman is then
hung on the gallows that he made for somebody else.
Right.
So deliverance comes in this kind of turn of events
where God's people are delivered and he is judged
and he is punished for his wrongdoing, his his evil plans.
So sin will be paid for sooner or later,
whether it's in our lifetime where you were the somebody falls into the pit
or or whether it is it is ultimate.
But justice is coming.
And here in Psalm seven, God has spoken of as a righteous judge.
When you come to the New Testament, we also see that this same God has appointed
Jesus as the judge.
So when Jesus came the first time, he came as a savior.
But when he comes again, he is coming as as the judge who will bring about
ultimate justice.
So when the Apostle Paul preached in Acts 1731, he said, God has fixed
a day on which he will judge the world in righteousness
by a man whom he has appointed.
And this he has given assurance to of this he has given assurance to all
by raising him from the dead.
So it is Jesus himself, our savior who is coming to judge the world in righteousness.
So we may feel the cruel injustice of the world and wonder why
God hasn't brought it to an end.
Like if he is just, why is all this allowed to continue on?
Well, the dilemma that's presented is that if God comes and establishes perfect
justice, if he brings all the all the injustice to an end,
well, what does that mean for people who are unjust?
Or so it's not just about bringing unjust injustice to an end in a general sense.
If he if he brings justice, that also brings judgment on those who commit
acts of injustice.
It's even deeper than that because here the Psalmist, he doesn't just speak
about acts of injustice, the attacks that take place or the lies.
He talks about the condition of the hearts of the people who are committing those things.
So you see that in that in that image that is there in verse 14.
So what's happening begins on the inside of these evil people,
and it's making their way and making its way out.
So their sinful hearts are the source of their lies and their attacks,
ultimately.
So the unjust things that are taking place in the world are ultimately the
results of the sin that resides in human hearts.
So injustice isn't just an out there problem.
It's an in here problem.
Unjust actions flow from the corruption of a human heart that is unjust.
And this is something that affects us all.
So the justice that we long for, see everything made right, that will
happen when Jesus returns is going to happen.
But that will include the judgment of those whose hearts are not right with God.
So how should we respond knowing that when Jesus returns, he will return
as a righteous judge?
Well, first of all, we should repent.
But that is that is the Apostle Paul's message in Acts 17.
When he when he's preaching about Jesus returning as a judge, he's calling.
He said, God is now calling all people everywhere to repentance.
And this is what you see in verse 12, you know, saying, if man does not repent,
God is going to bring this punishment.
Right. So so there's there's a positive side of that.
So now is a time when we can repent and escape the judgment of God and know
him as our refuge instead of just as judge.
This God is ready to save anyone who is ready to repent, even though
they yes, they deserve this just judgment.
He will forgive those who are willing to repent.
And this is why Jesus hasn't returned yet.
This is not just me trying to connect the dots of why he's not returned yet.
So Second Peter, chapter three and verse nine, people are saying, well,
why hasn't Jesus returned yet?
Here's why it says says the Lord is not slow concerning his promise.
As some people count slowness, right? He promised to return.
It's not that just dragging his feet here.
He says he's not returned because he is long suffering to us, not willing
that any should perish, but that all should come to repentance.
That's when he comes, he's bringing justice.
Why hasn't it come back yet?
So that more people can be brought to repentance.
So they can be forgiven.
And they can be received in his righteousness.
So now is the time to to repent, to turn from our sin and to put our trust
in Jesus as our savior and king.
So we should respond to seeing Christ as judge by repenting, putting our trust in him.
But also secondly, this is the last thing I'm going to say.
There's a call here to rejoice in him as the righteous judge.
So let's read verse 17.
I will give to the Lord the thanks due to his righteousness.
And I will sing praise to the name of the Lord, the most high.
So let's not remember, let's not forget that this is a song.
You know, I've been listening over the past few weeks to
to songs from the kind of folk revival of the 1960s.
I may be the only person in this room who's been listening to that.
But I've kind of really, really gotten into that, listening to some of it
and just seeing some of the overlap of that and then the civil rights movement,
how some of those songs end up being some of the songs, you know, we, you know,
we shall overcome things like that that are being sung.
Some kind of amazing movement that was happening in music was a huge part of that.
And you're listening to these songs, you realize, well, this is these songs
are a way of like, yes, experiencing these troubles and getting through it.
But there was a real sense of of hope in these songs.
And we're like on the cusp of change, like justice is coming.
So there's there's a gladness that comes with the with the struggle
and the singing that is in it.
So we have a song that we're reading here in Psalm seven.
Let's not forget this is this is music here.
And this is a this is a song celebrating the justice of God
that recognizes hardship, but that says, yes, justice is coming.
So this song has that kind of that kind of ring to it.
It's a song celebrating God's justice.
Yes, things are hard, but there is a day coming when justice will roll
down like waters and righteousness like an ever flowing stream.
As Amos said, in Amos five, twenty four,
one day every wrong will be made right.
And our good king will reign in righteousness forever.
And so to pray to our righteous judge is to pray in hope, looking forward.
In hopeful anticipation of that day.
Well, we're going to come now to to our time of communion together.
And so as we as we observe communion, we are remembering
what Jesus has done for us in receiving the judgment that we deserved
in his body and his death on the cross.
But we're also remembering that he is coming again.
And on that day, we will we will then dwell with him forever.
I mean, we will feast in his presence in his kingdom forever more.
So let me read 1 Corinthians chapter 11, which which ties those two things
together. And then I'll then I'll pray.
As far as see from the Lord, what I also delivered to you that the Lord Jesus
on the night when he was betrayed took bread.
When he had given thanks, he broke it and said, this is my body,
which is for you. Do this in remembrance of me.
In the same way also, he took the cup after supper, saying, this cup is the new
covenant in my blood. Do this as often as you drink it in remembrance of me.
As often as you eat this bread and drink this cup, you proclaim the Lord's
death until he comes.
So as we're coming to this this table, we are coming in repentance.
We're coming humbly before the Lord, reliant on his mercy, remembering that
Jesus died for us.
He took our judgment.
We're coming also in a celebration where we're joicing in what he's done for us
and all that we have in it.
Well, thank you that that can be the case because of what you have done
for us in Jesus.
Well, we thank you that though we sin against you.
Well, that Jesus took our sin upon himself.
He received in this on body the judgment that we were due.
We might come to you in his righteousness.
So we want to come to you humbly thanking you for what you've done for us
in Christ. We want to come to you in faith, believing and rejoicing in what
you've done for us in him.